welcome to the man of recaps this is
better call saul the sixth and final
season this final season does not begin
with the black and white cinnabon flash
forward to the present we're gonna be
spending more time there later for now
we pick up where season five ended with
gus fring's failed assassination attempt
of lalo salamanca who is now a real mad
but everyone thinks lalo was killed as
one of the bodies is badly burnt and
lala's laying low happy to let the world
think he's dead the only person he calls
is his uncle hector salamanca like i
know gus fring was behind this i'm gonna
find proof and we'll bring the chicken
man down the cartel figured out nacho
was involved so he's on the run until
mike can set him up at a safe house mike
german trout's like hey nacho is a good
guy we gotta bring him home safe but gus
fring's like no he's gotta take the fall
he plants evidence nachos working for
the colombians and lets the cartel find
him so nacho has an epic shootout with
the murder twins but he understands
there's no way he survives this the one
thing he can do is make a deal to have
his father taken care of and so they
fake it that gus friend captured him and
nacho gives a nice clean confession that
it was the colombians who paid him and
before they can ask any follow-up
questions nacho grabs the gun and shoots
himself no nacho was such a good guy and
a great character and that's how his
story comes to an end now back to jimmy
mcgill aka saul goodman business is
booming his law practice has outgrown
the back of the nail salon so finally he
rents his own place and saul goodman's
getting closer to his final form the
main focus of the season is jimmy and
kim's big con of their former boss
howard hamlin remember he's the head of
the sandpiper case the mega class action
lawsuit that jimmy started in the early
seasons lawsuits like this take years to
settle but if they can impeach howard's
character it'll make him settle early
and jimmy walks away with a buttload of
cash jimmy and kim have an elaborate
multi-step con to basically make it look
like howard's a cokehead the best part
is when jimmy dresses as howard and
borrows his iconic namaste car and acts
erratically in front of his co-workers
when they confront howard he's like yo
it wasn't me he knows jimmy's messing
with him so he hires an investigator to
follow jimmy but that's part of the con
2 this guy's working for jimmy for the
grand finale they stitch a fake photo
shoot to make it look like jimmy's
bribed the sandpiper mediator but by
chance jimmy runs into the real mediator
who has a broken arm so it's all hands
on deck to do a reshoot before the big
meeting so the fake investigator gets
howard the fake photos and when the
meeting starts he recognizes this
mediator is compromised he calls him out
and makes a big scene but when he gets
the photos that would prove it the
investigator swapped him they're just
innocuous photos so now howard looks
real crazy it's like hey man you got a
problem we're gonna have to settle this
case huge success for jimmy and kim now
back to gus fring who's in full lockdown
mode he's even got a secret tunnel in
his suburban house to the next door
neighbors which is a security
headquarters my girlfriend trout's like
hey it looks like lalo's really dead we
don't have to do this but gus fring
knows he's still out there but low's not
in albuquerque he's in germany following
his one lead of the construction worker
werner ziegler he basically goes on a
date with his widow which leads him to
one of the construction workers who
finally give some answers now lalo knows
all about the secret meth lab under the
laundromat so now jimmy and kim are
celebrating a successful con when howard
hamlin shows up as they knew he would i
can't prove it but i know you guys were
behind this you should be ashamed of
yourselves but just then someone else
shows up it is lalo salamanca howard's
like huh who's this guy and blam lalo
kills him right then jimmy and kim got
him killed because he was in the wrong
place at the wrong time lala's like hey
hope you didn't like that guy because we
need to talk he's come to them to run a
distraction play he keeps all his
leverage while he sends kim to go out
and attempt to assassinate gus frank
which of course doesn't work at all they
capture her immediately and she tells
him lalo is under apartment so it's all
hands on deck to get lalo but of course
he's not still here he's used the
opportunity to sneak into the laundromat
gus frane figures it out and gets down
there but lalo gets the jump on him and
now he's got the chicken man right where
he wants him he gets video evidence that
gus is trying to cut the cartel out by
building his own secret meth lab here
stateside so now he finally gets to kill
him but gus frank's not done yet makes a
final move kicks the power grabs a gun
and it's a shootout and when the smoke
clears gustavo fring is still standing
and lalo salamanca is dead and so this
lalo business is neatly wrapped up old
man hector still no strings guilty but
he can't prove it so donald oddio sides
with frank leaving gus ring free to
eventually in breaking bad exact his
revenge our poor lawyers jimmy and kim
who got wrapped up in this are now
racked with guilt over howard's death
and it's finally too much for kim wexler
to handle jimmy's like come on kim we
can get past this but she's like no i
can't i love you i've had fun conning
with you but we are bad for each other
and she leaves him for good immediately
after that there's a time jump as jimmy
mcgill is living in his gaudy expensive
house with a closet full of colorful
shirts and ties his lawyer up license
plate and his office now decorated in
its ridiculous fashion jimmy mcgill is
no more saul goodman has reached his
final form in fact we catch up to his
introduction in breaking bad and get a
scene with a cameo from jesse pinkman
and walter white and now it's time to
see what happens to saul after breaking
bad with the black and white cinnabon
flash forward remember he's in hiding as
gene the manager of a cinnabon in
nebraska but in the season 5 intro he
just got made by a cab driver who used
to live in albuquerque and immediately
recognized him as better call saul he
befriends this old lady who is the cab
driver's mother as a subtle threat but
then he's like hey man i'll set you up
with one big score then you and me are
done so at the mall gene befriends the
nighttime security guards like hey
thanks for your work guys here's some
free cinnabons she makes it a regular
thing really befriends this guard who
always turns away from the cameras while
he eats and salt times exactly how long
it takes him to finish a cinnabon so he
can train the taxi driver for an epic of
all heist on the big night it's all
going great until this guy slips on the
tile and saul's got a fake a mental
breakdown to keep this guy from turning
around but in the end it was a huge
success and saul's like hey stick with
me i got a lot more ideas saul starts
running his old school cons where he
befriends rich douche bags and bars and
at the end of the night it's his taxi
driver who picks him up he gives them a
water list with some drugs so they're
out cold that night there are other guys
able to sneak in take pictures of all
their financial documents so these guys
wake up think they just drank too much
and don't even know they've been robbed
until months later and saul's loving it
he's back in the game in fact he's
feeling so good that one day he decides
to call kim wexler she started a whole
new life she's resigned as a lawyer and
moved to florida where she's got a
boring job and a boring boyfriend but
it's all shaken up by this call from her
fugitive ex-husband like hey how you
doing she's like jimmy i don't want to
reconnect you should turn yourself in
but saul did not want to hear this he's
pretty angry and now he gets reckless
his next target's actually a nice guy
and has cancer so saul's partner is like
yo i'm not going to rip this guy off but
saul's like fine i'll do it myself so he
goes there breaks the window gets in
there he's almost caught and outside the
taxi driver gets nervous attracts some
police attention but it's actually his
mom who starts to get suspicious of jean
and when saul lets it slip he used to
live in albuquerque a little google
search better call saul she calls her
lifeline saul goodman's in my kitchen
and sews saul's on the run again it
doesn't last long pretty soon he's
caught and with walter white dead and
jesse pinkman missing they really want
to bring the hammer down on saul but
saul goodman is not intimidated he's
going to talk his way out of this
basically his defense is that he's a
victim too walter white threatened his
life and he was just helping him out of
fear and so working his magic he's able
to get an insanely good deal just seven
years at a resort style prison but he's
hit with a curveball when he learns that
kim wexler went and confessed to their
involvement in howard hamlin's murder
yes after her call with jimmy she
couldn't hold it in anymore flew to
albuquerque and wrote a full statement
then had a breakdown on the bus she's
not going to jail for it though howard's
widow is hitting her with a big civil
suit the main thing was she just wanted
to get the truth off her chest so now
when salt sees him in court he has a
change of heart he throws away his great
cushy deal by telling the truth i wasn't
under duress i wanted to help walter
white to make a buttload of money and in
a great call back to the early seasons
he talks about his brother chuck and
admits to himself and the court it
really was his fault that chuck killed
himself so his conscience is clean and
in a symbolic moment he's like hey i'm
not sol goodman call me jimmy mcgill but
on his way to a life sentence in prison
all the other inmates are like hey
aren't you better call saul and we get
to see that saul's having a decent
prison life enjoying his status as kind
of a legend in fact he gets a visit from
kim and they share a cigarette like they
used to do unless they work some serious
magic jimmy's not getting out anytime
soon so it's not to happily ever after
but at least coming clean has earned
jimmy kim's respect and love once again
and that is where better call saul comes
to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]